hi guys so I just wanted to share this
little video with you I'm really excited
because there was the show that I
started watching a few months ago called
the beautiful life I just randomly was
searching on iTunes for new shows to
watch and I found it but then came the
bad news it got cancelled because no one
even knew about it so bla bla bla bla
long story short I was upset because I
just started getting into the show and
there were no more episodes to watch but
Ashton Kutcher who was an executive
producer of the show has a little
announcement to make
and I hope to make it hello my name is
Ashton Crutcher I have a special guest
here with me today
this is the special guest well I'm
excited because the beautiful life is
now released we weren't supposed to tell
them when you already told them that the
beautiful life is being released on the
web we're supposed to be doing I didn't
think what we were doing that though I
thought we were gonna have like I do
like a thing before we told them now
they already know I'm sorry the
beautiful life is gonna be released
online here's what happened
we put the show on TV and went for two
episodes nobody knew it was on I've got
odd the rating on the TV wasn't
happening I was like listen we put this
thing on the web more than a half a
million people will watch it on the web
and beautiful programming without
commercial interruption no commercial
interruption on the internet and on the
internet but feel free to check out the
beautiful life on YouTube and watch the
rest of this video with Ashton and I
their YouTube channel is youtube.com
slash TBL that stands for the beautiful
life so let me know what you guys think
of the show did you like it what did you
like about it anything feel free to
leave a comment and be sure to go check
out their YouTube channel it's so crazy
to me to see some people here on YouTube
that are getting more views than network
television shows are getting so to have
a good show
come here and live it some home on
YouTube I'm excited this is such a great
community and you guys are so amazing
and it makes so many amazing videos and
I love reading your comments
and a little motional here I love you
okay that's it
fine